[Music]
i want another nurse
well there are none we're stretched
pretty thin right now then i want a
janitor they can do what you do right
yep nurses and janitors are totally
interchangeable except no one dresses up
like a janitor when they want to be
[ __ ]
i get the sense that maybe you're angry
at me for kissing andy
no i'm not what are you talking about
that's crazy and that you think it might
be fun to take it out on me
please don't do that do i can't do
anything
i'm sick
[Music]
my blankets are on the floor
stay back [ __ ] april you finalized a
rental right
shut up anne i told you never to talk to
me
that was champion oh my god i'm sorry
bad dog yes everything's fine with the
rental i wish you weren't right but you
are
you have turned into a very beautiful
wise and fertile
government employee stop
it's kind of weird when she just starts
raining compliments on you huh don't try
to bond with me
can't win anyone find any mistakes
yeah actually in here it says the pawnee
is
great but in reality it's terrible
let tom know we haven't found anything
hey i'm thinking about getting a new
phone do you guys like your phones i've
never used a phone in my life
what about you ron do you like your
phone um
here's my goal i'm gonna get these two
people that i've known for a long time
to talk to me for five minutes
who am i kidding one minute one minute
would be amazing
morning is leslie here
oh man i am so tired i took a half shift
at the hospital last night
and i had this really weird patient
weird how
i probably shouldn't talk about as one
of the grossest things i've ever seen
talk well this guy came in he got his
hand stuck in a pringles can
and he tried to cut himself out what
kind of blade did he use
uh three and a half inch serrated
buckets of blood he passed out over his
arm
and slumped onto the floor to the boncho
very good question april answer her
yeah the bone showed everyone in the
universe loves a gross medical story
boom i win and so when i finally cleaned
up the vomit
i found the toe i forgot about the towel
so did we
crazy right that story is awesome indeed
thank you for sharing jenny
ann perkins is currently attending the
valentine's day dance alone
so i need each one of you to bring an
eligible bachelor for her tomorrow
anne's not
totally hideous why does she need our
help because that's what friends do
april
they help friends find happiness hey
you're here
and i brought a bachelor are you kidding
me
no you brought oren ann is not some
weird morose mummy offense intended oren
let this be a wake-up call about the way
you present yourself to the world
i think ann and him would be cute
together thanks for nothing why should i
do anything to help her
because despite the fact that all you do
is give her a hard time
she would do this for you just go hide
under the table with your friend oren
yeah i see you weirdo
april tom and ann are on a date
i know what do you mean no how do you
know
cause i set them up
man i need to like wrap my head around
this why it makes sense to me
this is a small loser town loser people
tom's like at least semi-cool you know
what i'm hearing
you tried to make anne happy for
valentine's day
oh you're a very nice person yes you are
very nice
i guess it would have to be channing
tatum's body
ryan gosling's face and michael
fassbender's
sense of humor what about you build your
perfect guy
um yao ming's torso
napoleon's brain and the hunchback of
notre dame's hunchback
do you like my nails even though she
hides it underneath
layers of sarcasm resentment and
grumpiness i know
deep down somewhere april likes me i'm
kind of just fracking for friendship
are you ready for you to tell me what's
going on with chris yes no
to sing if you're lost you can look and
you will
find me time after time
go no tell me about chris if you fall i
will catch you i'll be
waiting tell me about chris where i'm
leaving and i don't care about the
letter
i want to have a baby and i asked chris
to donate his sperm and he's taking a
really long time to make up his mind and
it's really freaking me out and i can't
stop thinking about it
and i'm obsessing about it i want to
think about anything else but that but
it's making me crazy
secrets stolen
from deep inside you know this song
already of course i do everyone knows
the song it's amazing
the drum beats out of time if you're
lost you can look and you will
find me time after time
if you fall i will catch you oh i'll be
waiting
time after time time after time
time after time
good stuff it's never happened
here is your letter of recommendation so
you're off the hook
no need to pretend to be my friend
anymore thank god
i can't tell if you actually hate me or
this is just how you are
but i had fun hanging out with you so
i don't care what you say you're my
friend and i hope you get into
veterinary school because i like you
so there i got you something too
baby naming book i hope it works out
with chris and if it doesn't i hope it
works out with someone
we're gonna hug now oh yeah ow you're
hurting me
yippee road trip who's excited to go to
bloomington is that where you're gonna
sit
i'm driving where else would i sit trunk
i helped april get into vet school in
bloomington and today's her orientation
so we're taking a little road trip while
i'm there i'm also going to pick up an
organic baby blanket
i would get one of pawnee but fun fact
our only baby store is attached to a
chemical refinery
i made a special road trip mix cd for us
i hope you like toriyamus
oh cool
all right so you have everything you
need for orientation yeah an
empty sprite can an old man's fingernail
in my pocket and
a picture of patrick ewing on a roller
coaster i'm all set
great hi you're back hello again
as you remember i'm april and this is
anne my 65 year old grandmother
yes that's who i am anyway we'd love to
hear about bloomington it seems like a
real hip kind of college town me ma god
no one uses the word hip anymore
sometimes i wish you went down on the
titanic with all your sorority sisters
i'm not going to school here april don't
flake out on this you're gonna love it
here bloomington is
great it's got culture and music and
tons of
youngsters youngsters am i 65 years old
yeah i'm not going here i don't want to
let's leave
can we please talk about what happened
back there what and i just stole your
phone and texted every guy in it that
the baby was there
it's not that big of a deal listen i
know you don't believe this but i
care about your future and i'm just a
little disappointed that you're just not
following through with this
yeah it's not about following through
okay i was on the fence about whether i
wanted to do it and as soon as i got
there i just
had a gut feeling that it wasn't right
for me that's all so just like that
boom huge life decision made that's how
i make all my life decisions
my gut is always right okay it was right
about marrying andy
and it was right when it told me that
you would be the worst person i would
ever meet in my life
and i've met guy fieri and
so gross how do you get your gut to talk
to you
you don't get your gut to talk to you
you just listen when it says something
well right now my gut is saying that we
are going to listen to mariah carey
the whole way home good
[Music]
well let's go set up this party april
thank you
i know you may tease ann but deep down
inside i can tell that you really care
anne's leaving town and saying painful
goodbyes to loved ones
greatest day of my life okay
don't mention anything about the
groundbreaking to ann repeat that back
to me
tell anne about the groundbreaking frame
and for murder release a deadly virus
into the water supply good looks like we
hit a wall
oh god
are you okay what's happening i'm just
so scared that this means that ann won't
really leave
pawnee raccoons that is one thing i will
not miss
well michigan has wolverines maybe
they'll eat your toes
so how long do you think you'll stay in
pawnee for i don't know
we like it here i made andy promise that
someday we'll move to transylvania but
that probably won't happen until we're
like
a hundred well for what it's worth
i'm really happy that you and andy are
married why
why because i love him and
i love you why wouldn't i be happy
why aren't you what's that
i love you too i i couldn't i couldn't
quite hear you please don't make me say
it
please my going away present to you
will be that i do not make you audibly
say that you love me
thank you
okay leslie's coming back get off me
wench did i miss a nice moment no
yes you did
you